- Welcome, everyone
to the first of our
two-part webinar series
on the 2022 midterm elections
sponsored by Yale's Institution
for Social and Policy Studies,
which is known as ISPS.
My name is Alan Gerber.
I'm a professor at Yale
in the Department of Political
Science and Director of ISPS.
And today I'm very
excited to share with you
the insights of our expert panel,
and I'll be introducing them shortly.
So first, I just wanna encourage you,
there's a good amount
of time in the webinar
for question and answer.
And so please send questions for the panel
at any time through the
Q&A button at the bottom
of your Zoom screen.
And please try,
we're gonna try and read
the questions that you ask
to capture your own voice.
And so we'll be able to do that
if you keep the questions brief
and in a form that's easy for us to field
to our colleagues on the panel.
And I just wanna also
say that today's event
is being recorded and
we'll be posting the link
of the video as soon as possible.
And then also for those
of you who are on Twitter,
our handle is @ispsyale.
And you can also use
the #ispsmidterms2022.
I wanna begin by thanking the staff,
the people in the Yale community
who really make all the events
that we do here at ISPS possible.
I wanna give special thanks to Pam Greene,
Rick Harrison, Limor Peer,
and Kira Wishart for all they do
to help ISPS fulfill its
research and education mission.
And then the rhythm of the
event tonight will be this.
The panelists will speak
for five to seven minutes.
When they're finished,
we're gonna have a discussion
among the panelists
for maybe 20 minutes or so,
and then that'll be followed
by a question and answer period
where the questions that
you've been sending us
during the panel phase
will be fielded to the panelists.
And with that, I just wanna
introduce today's panel
who will be presenting
in alphabetical order.
So first, Mo Fiorina.
Oh, these are gonna be
brief introductions,
because I just wanna leave
as much time as possible
for the presentations, discussion,
and question and answer.
So, and these are very
distinguished people,
so it could go on for a while
if I went through the whole thing.
Okay, so Mo Fiorina is
a professor at Stanford.
He's the Wendt Family
professor of political science,
author of many books,
and the member of many
distinguished academic societies,
including the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences
and the National Academy of Sciences.
Josh Kalla is our second presenter.
Josh is an assistant professor
of political science at Yale
and is also in the
Department of Statistics
and Data Science,
and a resident fellow of ISPS.
He works on political persuasion,
prejudice reduction,
decision making among voters
and political elites,
and he's won a number of awards
to recognize the scholarship,
including the Leamer-Rosenthal
for Open Social Science.
Mike Podhorzer is the
former political director
of the AFL-CIO.
He's also the founding chair
of the Analyst Institute
and one of the most important
institutional actors
in progressive politics
over the past few decades.
We're extremely privileged
to have him joining us today.
And then finally, Lynn Vavreck.
Lynn is the Marvin Hoffenberg Professor
of American Politics and
Public Policy at UCLA.
Lynn has been a pioneer in many areas
in American political behavior.
Recently in 2020,
she led the Nationscape Election Project,
the largest study of
presidential elections
ever fielded in the United States.
She's also the recipient
of numerous awards
and the author of numerous books.
Her awards include the
Andrew Carnegie Prize
in the Humanities and Social Sciences.
And with that, let me turn
it over to our panelists
who will speak in alphabetic order.
- Okay, well, our instructions,
Professor Gerber asked us not to make more
than two or three arguments.
I'll do better than that.
I'm not gonna make any arguments.
I'll give you one not so courageous guess.
And the reason for that is,
normally after every election,
there is a narrative that
takes hold about what happened.
And often the narrative is wrong
when we actually do our analyses.
But at least you have
something to argue against.
In this election, there
are just any number
of competing narratives out there.
The election, depending
on who you talk to,
was about abortion, or was
about election denying,
or was about January 6th
and the threat to democracy,
and the critical groups or independents
or young people or suburban residents
or women or young women or
young college educated women.
And I'm not gonna go
to any of these places.
I think we have some real data
gurus on the program here,
and I'll let them
have all those kinds of questions.
After the 2020 election,
which was disappointing for
the Democrats in the House,
not the presidency obviously,
but in the House they lost
13 seats, surprisingly.
And their margin was only, I believe nine.
And virtually every political
scientist in the country
said after the election, the next day,
"They're gonna lose the House
in the next election, 2022."
And let me start sharing my screen here.
You've probably all heard
this generalization,
but if you've never
actually seen the numbers,
this is a chart of midterm losses
from the Civil War on.
1900, 1902 doesn't really count there.
The size of the House was increased
and everybody gained seats,
although the incumbent party
didn't get as many as the others.
But basically won the
election, the New Deal.
And then not until Newt
Gingrich doubled down
on the Monica Lewinsky scandal in 1998,
in the aftermath of
2001 terrorist attacks,
did any incumbent party gain seats.
You can see the gain is
played below the line there.
The only question is
how many seats you lose?
Now why is it always below the line?
Well, there are a number
of theories out there,
but I basically think it's the idea
of a thermostatic electorate
is what explains it.
That neither party has a
majority of the country,
and to win in the election,
you basically have to appeal
to middle of the road-ers
unaffiliated, moderates, et cetera.
But then you govern basically according
to the dictates of your base.
And a certain number of
people who voted for you
in the previous election decide
that's not what they wanted.
And here's an example.
This is Barack Obama in November, 2008.
Now the country was about evenly split
on whether it'll elect
a moderate or liberal,
by having watched cap and trade,
medical care, Obamacare, et cetera.
About a quarter of the people
who thought he was a moderate
decided a year later, no,
they elected a liberal.
Hence, the schlacking
that occurred after that.
Political scientists have
developed forecasting models
to predict the seat losses.
They're basically models that
predict statistical models
based on economic conditions.
Presidential approval sucks up everything
other than the economy.
And there are variants
like, are we at war?
Are there war casualties?
How many seats do you have exposed
beyond your long-term average?
How long have you been in office?
And so forth.
And those models
sometimes work quite well.
And 2020, for example,
the average of the models was exactly on.
Now in 2022, those kind of models
were predicting unbelievable figures.
Seth Masket would
continually update these,
and he was always getting
figures like 60 seats.
And he, of course, didn't
believe that. No one else did.
Jim Campbell was one
of the few forecasters
who was willing to go public
and he said about 40 seats.
I checked with some of the
other forecasters informally,
and basically they were
reluctant to go public
because the models simply
seem to be making predictions
outside what was expected.
I think like many of the other panelists,
we had to give various talks.
And my pre-election prediction
to the Stanford newspaper
and other venues was,
I'd be very shocked if
anything other than something
between 49 to 51 seats for either party
occurred in the Senate,
and certainly no more than
30 seats in the House,
20 to 30 seats.
And the reason for the caution,
obviously, one, were fewer marginal seats,
fewer seats in the danger zone
after the last redistricting.
Second, Republicans already
hold a lot of seats.
I didn't see a lot of discussion of this
in the run up to the election.
In 1994, the Republican
wave of 54 seats in 2010,
the Democrats were lacking 63 seats.
In 2022, they had three
dozen more seats going in.
So it was really unlikely that
they were gonna have anything
like a 40 to 50 seat gain,
which is what Kevin McCarthy said.
The third thing was, of course, Dobbs,
and several of the forecasters
I talked to said simply
they just simply didn't know how
to take account of that in their models.
And frankly, you always have to count
Republican primary voters.
Just to go back on some
of the golden oldies
from the past, in 2010,
Christine O'Donnell had to run commercials
denying that she was a witch.
In 2012, we had a number
of comments about rape
that struck people and
was beyond the mainstream.
The Republican candidate
who ran against Bamberger
in Virginia actually got caught
in this argument this year.
She sort of sensed the danger,
but she basically
in one campaign appearance,
she actually agreed with this,
and it haunted her for
the rest of the campaign.
The all-time favorite,
I think, was this one.
These are, of course, Senate elections,
and we had a few candidates who were,
as Mitch McConnell said, not high quality.
This time I wasn't sure that'd
actually go to the House,
but we did have some
real sort of surprising candidates
in the House races as well.
So in summary, the
Republicans were likely to win
the House majority, not as
big as conditions suggest.
Senate majority was uncertain.
In the end, they gained only
nine seats in the House,
they gained only two governorships
and they lost a Senate seat.
And the story basically is the
independents didn't deliver
for the Republicans.
When you look back over time,
independents sort of determined the size
of these midterm losses.
Here's the Reagan era here.
Here's the Republican wave in '94.
Here's the Democrats slumping,
and they're really slumping in 2006,
and the Republicans
slacking in 2014, 2018.
The independents actually voted 2 or 3%,
probably before, according to some polls
for the Democrats this time.
So it was the independents
didn't have a very close margin.
They actually went for the Democrats.
And the last few elections
have not been kind
to the idea of a new Democratic majority
or the emerging Democratic majority.
People have put together
these from the Exit Polls
and the AP Poll.
African-Americans continue
to defect, to some extent,
Hispanics defect, working
class, suburban, old people.
Young people on the other
hand, more Democratic.
I really like Ruy Teixeira,
his blog, the Liberal Patriot.
He's a bit pessimistic on these things.
He likes to try to find the dark lining
in every silver cloud.
But his last blog the other day,
he's pointing out all the disadvantages
that the Democrats face,
even though they did find in the election,
like on immigration, the border,
they're 24 points down Republicans.
Crime, 20, economy and abortion,
20, or excuse me, economy, 20,
that should be inflation.
Abortion rights, they're
up a little of course,
and climate change, which
is not an important issue
to most people.
And of course on
traditional values, again,
the Democrats are the
disadvantage on these things.
So he sees dangers ahead
no matter what, how they managed to escape
oblivion in the last election.
And my guess is based on all this,
is that in general everything mattered.
Everything sort of added
up to the perception
that the Republicans were too extreme
and beyond the mainstream.
It was a little bit of all the things.
There was a nice third
way pre-election survey
in which people were
asked to place the parties
on the ideological spectrum.
And what was interesting is they actually
judged the parties to be equal,
not actually, judged the Democratic party
to be more extreme ideologically
than the Republican party.
But when asked about the
current candidates this year,
no, they felt the
Republicans had nominated
more extreme candidates this year.
So I'll end with that
and allow my fellow
panelists to flesh it out.
- Okay, so I think Mo and I,
as I was saying, we did not coordinate
in what we were talking about,
but really similar questions
and also similar answers.
But I think one question I have
coming out of this election
is did the Republicans
underperform in 2022?
And in order to answer that question,
we need to have some model as to how well
the Republicans should
have performed in 2022.
And one nice model out there,
there are many of these predictive models,
but one nice one is
from our Yale colleague
Ray Fair in the economics department,
where he talks about these different
pushes and pulls for or
against the incumbent party.
So based on the fact
that there's a democratic incumbent
and there's some both bias
against the White House,
that thermostatic public opinion
that Moe was talking about
canceled out by some incumbency effect,
but also the economy was both bad
with negative, very high inflation,
but also was good with high GDP growth.
All of this, when you
put this all together
in Ray Fair's model,
means that based on past election results,
we should have expected
the Republican vote share
in this election to be about 53.4%.
And what we ended up seeing
at least as of November 23rd,
is that the actual Republican vote share
in this election was about 51.6%.
So this means that
Republicans underperformed
relative to these historic models
based on the economy, based on incumbency,
based on how many seats they
were holding in the past.
Republicans seem to underperform
by about two percentage points.
So it does seem like Republicans,
based on what we have known in the past,
based on what we have
seen from past elections,
should have done better
than they ended up doing
this past November.
So then the obvious question
to ask next is, why?
And here I don't think we
have very solid answers.
But there's some
political science evidence
that we can point to suggest why it is
that Republicans might
have under-performed,
that Democrats might have over-performed.
And one piece of evidence we see
is that Democrats raised
and spent more money
than Republicans this election.
So in US House races,
Democrats spent about
$408 million on TV ads,
while Republican candidates
and affiliated groups
spent about $380 million on their TV ads.
And Lynn Vavreck, who's speaking later,
along with a few colleagues,
John Sides and Chris Warshaw,
have a really nice recent paper
in the "American
Political Science Review,"
showing that when one party
has an advertising advantage
over another party,
this leads to an electoral impact.
There is a benefit to spending
more ads than the other side.
And it's a pretty significant effect,
especially in down ballot races
like the House of Representatives
where Democrats out-performed
what these models would predict.
So I think one explanation
as to why Republicans
under-performed is they
might've just spent less money
than the Democratic party.
Another explanation, which
Mo talked a little bit about,
is about extremism,
about how Republican primaries
voted for candidates who
were just more extreme,
less high quality than who
the Democrats went for.
And again, there's really nice work
in political science by Andy Hall
now at Stanford, for example,
who looks at what happens when
more extreme candidates
win primary elections.
Is there an electoral penalty?
And one model of the win might say no,
there is no electoral penalty.
All that matters in
American politics today
is whether you have a D
or an R next to your name.
Democrats vote for Democrats,
Republicans vote for Republicans.
There are very, very few independents,
and all that matters is the
partisanship of who's running.
And that the extremism of
the individual candidates
does not matter.
And what Andy finds in this
paper is that view is wrong,
that individual candidates
do in fact matter.
More extreme candidates are punished
when it comes to the general election.
And there does seem to be
some evidence from this
in the most recent election.
The "New York Times" did
a really nice analysis
where they looked at US House races
where there was a " MAGA Republican"
who won the primary election
and ran in the general,
compared to all other Republican races.
And what you see when you just look at how
these MAGA versus non MAGA
Republicans did in 2022
relative to 2020,
is that the typical Republican,
the Chamber of Commerce Republican,
they actually did much better in 2022
than they did in 2020,
by about six points.
The issue for the Republican party
is that those MAGA Republicans
did much worse in 2022
relative to the 2020 benchmark.
They actually performed
about half a point worse.
So this really seems to suggest
that who the Republicans
ran in these elections might
have been a contributing factor
for the under-performance
of the Republican party.
And then the third, I think obvious point,
but I think a really open
point, is this backlash
to overturning Roe v.
Wade, the Dobbs decision.
And here I actually haven't seen any,
I think, convincing evidence
showing how or why to what extent
that Dobbs really mattered.
I think it very likely did.
But I think in just an open question,
I would love if the other panelists
have any thoughts on this,
is what data would actually
test whether or not,
or how would we know whether
or not Dobbs mattered?
'Cause likely it did.
But it would be nice to
be able to triangulate
with some data around that.
But that's it for me,
and I'll turn it over to Mike Podhorzer.
- [Michael] Thanks, Josh.
Actually gonna start in a
different place than I thought
because of how the
previous panelists started
before getting to my presentation.
And there's a couple, I know
Alan knows and Josh knows
(indistinct) who have, like,
been getting some of my stuff
for the last couple of years.
I thought the Democrats actually could
hold the House this year,
and that I went through
sort of two long years
of eye-rolling at me.
And that's because I think
what ended up happening
was that Republicans over-performed
from a very different perspective
than the modeling we just heard, right?
If you, in November, 2008,
right after Barack Obama won the election,
had been put in a medically induced coma
and then revived now,
and were told that in 2020
Donald Trump had been president,
lost the election,
staged a violent coup attempt,
and then the Republican party,
instead of distancing itself from him,
actually tripled down on him,
that the result was that they actually
took the House of Representatives, right?
Your head would explode.
And I think sometimes we pay
sort of too much attention
to the sort of...
The data in a very sort of myopic way
and not understand that
we're in a different
political time since 2016.
And that's what I'm gonna talk about.
So as folks were saying,
the result was not what
the model suggested
was gonna happen.
It's not what people who were following it
said were gonna happen.
And it isn't just that it didn't happen.
It happened, it didn't
happen in a spectacular way.
Since the Voting Rights Act,
these were the seven midterms
in which the president
was underwater and all the other things
are sort of going wrong.
There's only one where the
party picks up governor,
state legislative chambers,
has such a small loss.
It's completely ahistorical.
And if you even drill down
a little bit more, right?
It's as you just heard, nine seats lost
despite all those fundamentals
plus rising prices,
crime, all of that, double digit losses.
But if you go even
further, think about this.
In particular, Gretchen
Whitmer and Tony Evers,
won reelection by more
in the red election,
than they won in the blue wave, right?
And going back again to post-DRA,
like, that's not ever happened.
Democrats netting state
legislative chambers,
that's never happened.
Four democratic senators
were elected or reelected
from swing states.
This cycle, only three total
in any midterm since 1994
have been able to do that
against their president's party.
It's an astonishingly different
political environment.
And I think part of the
reason that people are,
we don't have a handle on it
is because of the explanations we get
for how this happened,
really don't match the data
or the moment that they're kind
of procrustean explanations,
swing voters, independents, all of that.
And I don't have a, obviously,
a conclusive answer,
but wanna offer a few observations
about a different way to think about it.
Right, so if procrustean,
right, is the idea is that
you, to make sure that your guest
gets the bed comfortably,
just cut off what doesn't fit, right?
And what our analysis of elections
since Trump had been doing is really
cutting off the effect of
differential partisan turnout,
the local political context
as opposed to race by race analysis.
And what the media's saying
in each of these markets
is really, it's only the media that gets
to really conclusively say
what's true and what's not.
And after 2016, right,
the turnout just became
something it never was, right?
Turnout went up by
almost 14 points in 2018,
twice as much as it ever
had since reconstruction,
which was twice as much as
it had ever gone before that.
We're just in a different turnout era.
And so almost all the analysis we've read
or heard about is about the
roughly 11 million people
who might be called swing
voters or independents
and the electorate, and nothing
about the 45 million people
who voted in 2020, but
stayed home this time, right?
Which is a very different situation
from historic midterms.
In historic midterms, about
3/4 of the electorate or more
were 4/4 voters.
And now that's down to
just under 50%, right?
There's just a big new pool of voters,
and no one's paying attention to 'em.
And that's where
these shifts are happening, right?
So the thing I want to put
out is that I don't think
that this was a red mist.
I think we actually had two
midterms in the country.
We had one midterm that was the red wave
that all those models were predicting,
and I shouldn't say
wave, but blue undertow.
And so the metric that I'm
gonna use in these couple slides
is presidential swing.
In each of the districts,
the difference between
what the Democrat got
and what Biden got two years ago,
limiting it to the 150 Closest Race,
just so it's comparable across
regions and time periods.
And because that's 60/40 and beyond that,
it really doesn't matter much.
Right, so the swing in
those 150 districts in 2018
was seven points away from Republicans
and four points away from Democrats.
And that's the mental
model that people have.
But if you split the
country into one country,
which is the what I'm
calling the MAGA war zone,
which are the, you know,
the electoral college states,
places where things are really fierce,
and the rest of the country,
you see that really
there was no difference
between the swing that Trump endured
and the swing that Democrats endured
in that part of the country.
But in the MAGA war zone,
Democrats did barely less well than Biden
did two years ago.
And because I would argue people, voters
in those states understood
this is playing for keeps,
real MAGA, no MAGA.
And the other way of sort of looking at it
in terms of the modeling was that
I did 538 Final Deluxe,
which has, like, all the
things they can throw into it,
and Democrats over-performed
the estimate for them
by 4.4 points in this MAGA war zone.
And they, 538, you know,
came as close to nailing
the rest of the districts,
as you can imagine.
And so the last thing is just to say that
this idea of missing voters, it's the,
and I'm sure we'll come
back to some questions,
but the dynamic that I think,
now there was clearly
switching and stuff like that,
but the dynamic is that
turnout went up among Democrats
in that MAGA war zone,
turnout among Republicans
was about the same
in both areas.
And one of the things
that this helps explain
that the bad candidate,
all the other kinds of,
you know, independent voter
explanations doesn't explain,
is why if you have an
independent, for example,
comes out and says, "Mastriano, oh my god.
I can't vote for them."
Did that person who other
than that were postulating,
would have been a thermostatic voter,
give Democrats big down
ballot gains in the state?
How did they flip the two chambers
in Michigan, right?
It is because the big driver
was that there were just more Democrats,
and it didn't matter
whether the Republican
was a denier or not,
just having decided to come out and vote
was what mattered.
And I'll stop there, because
that's my time. Sorry.
- Thanks, Mike.
I will kind of pick up a
whole bunch of those threads
and see if we can
tell a little bit of a broader story
about what is happening
in American politics
at this moment in time
and what it might mean for the future.
And so the stuff that
I'm gonna talk about here
in the next five or six
minutes comes from a book
that I've just written
called "The Bitter End"
with my colleague at
UCLA, Chris Tausanovitch
and my longtime co-author John Sides,
who is at Vanderbilt.
And our answer to this question
about what just happened
in the midterms and what is
happening in American politics
more generally, turns on
this idea of calcification.
And calcification sounds
a lot like polarization,
but it is not just polarization.
I like to say it's polarization plus.
And the plus is really important.
So there are four
components of polarization,
and I'll tell you what they are briefly.
Two of them are a long time in the making,
and two of them are more recent.
So the first two are sort
of long-term tectonic shifts
that have taken time.
And the last two you can think
of as little earthquakes,
shocks, that have happened recently.
The first two sound a
lot like polarization.
So an increasing homogeneity
within each of the parties.
So people who call themselves Democrats
are more alike than they've ever been
on issues, on ideology, possibly
even on characteristics.
Same thing for Republicans.
The second thing, is
an increasing distance
between the two parties.
Something that we've seen happen
in Congress for a long time
but is now happening in the electorate.
On average, people's
attitudes about policies
in the electorate are very far apart
when you sort them by political party.
The more recent things include a change
in the set of issues
that we're fighting over.
So the importance of
identity-inflected issues,
things that turn on race,
ethnicity, religion, gender.
So that would be things
like abortion, immigration,
the Muslim ban, separating
children at the border.
All of those kinds of person-based issues
have become the thing that
is contested politically,
as opposed to the New Deal type
of political contestation
that defined most of
politics in our lifetimes.
So the role and size of
government, the tax rate,
whether small businesses should
be taxed higher or lower,
whether low income families
should be taxed higher or lower.
Joe the plumber is the classic example.
If everybody remembers him
from the 2008 presidential campaign.
We don't fight, we're not fighting
over those things anymore.
So the dimension of conflict has shifted,
and that's something that
has taken about a decade.
That's the more recent.
The first two things are
multiple decades since the '60s,
the Civil Rights and Voting Rights Act.
These last two things are
within the last decade.
The final thing is partisan parity
within the electorate.
So a rough balance
between people calling
themselves Democrats
and people calling themselves
Republicans right now
in the electorate.
It's not a perfect balance,
but it's closer than it's been
in the last 70 or 80 years.
Those four things mashed up together
lead us to this state of politics
that we call calcification.
And just like in the human body,
calcification makes
things stiff and rigid.
Why?
Because the stakes of winning
elections are very high.
Why?
Because the other side is
farther away than ever.
And because of the partisan parity,
victory is always within
reach for both sides.
And we're fighting over
these extremely divisive,
person-based issues.
And so when you mash all
those things up together,
it becomes very difficult for voters,
say whose party nominated a candidate
who they don't think are high quality,
becomes very difficult
for those voters to say,
"Oh, well, okay, in
this particular election
I'm gonna cross over and
vote for the other side,
'cause I don't love the
person my party nominated."
We're talking about a couple
of points on the tax rate
or, you know, whether government
should really be involved in healthcare.
And maybe you can cross over.
But when you're saying,
"I don't think we should
be separating children
from their families at the border."
"I don't love the person
my party's nominated,
but, you know what, I'm
gonna vote for the person
who wants to separate the children,"
it's a completely different
kind of stretching
of your party affiliation
to vote for the other side.
And so this context has produced
this state of stickiness
that we call calcification.
So I wanna show you just a couple
of the consequences of calcification.
The first is that voters have
observed these differences
and appreciate them between the parties.
Very different worlds on offer
on these identity-inflected things
between Republicans and
Democrats, and voters know it.
So here I'm showing you
time on the horizontal axis,
and the share of people
on the vertical axis
who say they have seen
important differences
between the two political parties.
In 1952, you can see
for reasons that everybody can figure out,
only one out of two Americans thinks
there are important differences
between the two parties.
But today, that number is 90%.
So nine out of 10 Americans
think the two parties
have important differences.
So the first piece of evidence
that the state of politics
today is different for voters
than it has been at any previous point
over the last several decades.
Here's another implication
of calcification.
The emotional reaction
to political parties.
Here we're asking people
to rate their party
and the other party on a zero to 100 scale
that's like a thermometer.
100 is very cold, you don't like them.
Sorry, zero is very cold,
you don't like them.
100 is hot, you do like them.
50 is neutral, take it or leave it.
So people have always
liked their own party.
Putting it up here in the 19,
or sorry, in the 70 rating range
from 1978 to the present day.
But they like the
opposite party a lot less
than they used to.
We used to have neutral
feelings about the out party.
And now you can see we're down here at 19.
People really dislike the opposite party.
That emotional reaction can
be based on a lot of things.
But certainly a component
is the figure I showed
you just a minute ago,
that people perceive important differences
in the kind of world
that each of these parties wanna create.
And they don't like the world
that the out party wants to create.
Another consequence of calcification
is something that you've heard a couple
of the other panelists talk about,
that elections are becoming tighter.
There's less swing.
And so very quickly, I'm
just showing you here
the two-party vote share for the Democrats
between '08 and '12, between '12 and '16,
and then between '16 and '20.
Each dot is a state.
And this diagonal 45 degree line
would be where the dots would all be
if the Democratic party got
the same share of the vote
in the '08 election, for
example, and the '12 election.
So you can quickly see the
dots are not on the line.
Between '08 and '12, the
dots are below the line
indicating that in every state,
Obama did worse in '12 than he did in '08.
Easy to understand.
He gets a big boost
and wins in a landslide
because of the global financial crisis.
And then in 2012, some
of those voters peel off.
This one's a little more complicated.
Hillary Clinton picking
up votes relative to Obama
in states like California,
Arizona, and Texas.
But losing them in states like
Ohio, Pennsylvania and Iowa.
This is a reshuffling of the states
into a new equilibrium
that you can see persisting
between 2016 and 2020.
How do you see that?
Because all of these dots
are very close to the line
and they are almost on the line.
This tells us that the 2020
election was almost a replay
of the 2016 presidential election.
Very few people, there could be, you know,
Mike just talked about turnout.
That's really important to hear.
There could be different people
turning out in these elections,
but the outcome of these
elections state by state
is very close '16 to '20.
You can see it at the
county level as well.
Here we're showing you over time
the average county level
swing from the last election
to the one that is indicated
on the horizontal axis.
Some of the swings have been very big.
20 point average county swings
in presidential election
outcomes in the '60s and '70s.
But you can see over time, this
county swing is going down.
In 2020, it's the smallest
value it has ever been.
It's about three percentage points.
That's calcification.
Everything is more the same
and looks a lot like the last time
relative to what we've seen in the past.
And then finally, just to wrap up,
what about what just happened?
Here's the Georgia runoff.
Ooh, sorry.
Didn't mean to to hit that button.
Okay, here's 2021 on the
left and 2022 on the right.
And if you just stare
at this and look at it,
you will be able to see
that they're very similar.
A lot of red at the top in both places.
Blue around the urban areas
and the college campuses.
Almost everywhere except
for the right hand part
of the state here,
which became a little redder in 2022.
It looks very similar.
That's calcification
in this runoff election
just in Georgia.
And then finally, another sense of, like,
the difference between the two parties,
it's just to look at a couple counties.
So here's a red county just
outside of Atlanta, okay?
And 70/30 roughly, for Walker.
An adjacent county
right here near Atlanta,
80/20 for Warnock.
These are people living
in the suburbs of Atlanta.
They're roughly living
the same kind of lives,
but they're living in
very different places
and they know it and they appreciate it.
And all of this is leading
to this sense of being stuck.
Don't want the world that
the other side is offering.
And the idea that calcification,
because the stakes of
elections are so high,
the other side is far away,
has left us at a point where
very little is gonna change.
These elections are gonna
be very close going forward.
And that means that literally anything
could be flipping them.
Calcification doesn't mean
the same side always wins,
it means the elections
are gonna be razor thin.
All those things Mike just talked about,
all the things that Josh
and Mo talked about,
are going to be swinging these elections,
and the era of the
blowout is probably gone.
How long is it gonna last?
My guess is probably
the rest of my lifetime.
But a new dimension of
conflict is what we need
in order to shift us out
of this current state.
And we could spend a lot of time
thinking about exactly what that is.
And I'll end there.
And I think we're all gonna come back on.
Is that right, Alan?
- Yes. Yes, it is, Lynn.
Yes, it is.
Okay, terrific.
So let's take a few seconds
for the panel to reassemble.
While we're doing that,
let me again urge our audience members
to formulate and share their questions
in the Q&A.
There are some questions now and we're,
I'd be very interested in
knowing what your questions are
so the panelists can
address those questions.
So let me just start by
asking the panelists,
these were four, I think very interesting
and fairly different presentations.
One of the great things about a panel is
you get to actually react and
talk to your fellow panelists.
Does anyone just wanna start with,
and I hope we'll be able to
do this for a few minutes.
Let's see if this actually works.
Do you have a question you'd like to ask
or comment you'd like to make
about something that
one of your fellow panelists
presented on, either one
of their observations
or conclusions or something like that?
And...
I see great eagerness among our panel.
- I'll ask.
- Lynn, please just go right ahead.
- Okay, so. Hi, Mo.
You mentioned the swing voters,
and that we've always known
that campaigns were playing
to these people who were
the swing in the middle.
And I wondered if you thought that
that share of the electorate
has gotten smaller.
So obviously the margin
is still really important,
but, you know, maybe if we
used to have swing voters
that were this much, now it's this much.
I wonder, can you say a little bit
about how you think of that?
- Sure. Am I on?
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I think it has gotten smaller,
but no less important.
In fact, more important that
what you talked about earlier,
the parity of the parties.
It doesn't matter if
the swing voters are 2%,
if the parties are divided 49/49,
they still determine the election.
So essentially, you know, it doesn't,
they don't have to be a huge
quantity to decide an election.
Now, I do take issue with this belief
among journalists and among
younger political scientists
that nearly all leaning independents
are in fact closet partisans.
And I have evidence against
that in my last book,
but nobody seems to
have read that chapter.
I can't remember.
But anyway, because they switch
from election to election,
the same person who says,
"I'm leaning independent"
in one election tells you,
"I'm leaning Democrat"
in one election, then tells
you, "I'm leaning Republican"
in the next election.
So their party idea, their leaning,
is following their vote
decision rather than vice versa.
But yeah, I think in an era
of closed party competition,
the independents whatever
their size, the middle ground,
I mean, and by the way,
independents are not all
principled centrists.
They're just, they're moderates.
They are people who are
disengaged from politics.
They are cross pressured people
who don't really like either party.
They're clueless people, you know.
They're this, but they,
the thing they have in
common is they're volatile.
That particular campaign and candidates
can make them change their
votes from election to election.
So they're in the driver's
seat basically in this era.
- Yeah, if I can jump in
on the independent point
for a minute,
and get something I
sort of tried to wave at
in what I was saying,
is that I think that,
some of you know this,
that we really limited our imagination
of how politics happens to
what we can see in polls.
And so on the independent point, right?
I think one of the things
we saw this time around,
and part of what I was trying
to get at in the difference
between living in a MAGA
war zone state and not,
is that the people around you
have a very different feeling
about what's at stake
in the election, right?
And so if you were in Georgia,
you understood that even if
you thought Herschel Walker
was the biggest idiot in the world,
that you didn't want Chuck Schumer
to be majority leader,
and you knew exactly
what you were voting on.
It wasn't about issues,
it wasn't about any of those things.
On the other hand,
I am as convinced as you
can be about this stuff,
that there were a lot of
folks who voted for Biden
in California and New York
who did not understand
that by staying home they were making
Kevin McCarthy speaker.
Because no one was talking about it.
No one was saying that there
was this national dimension
to the election in that
kind of hot house way
it was in the other states.
And you're just not gonna
see that on a poll, right?
But that is actually how the world works.
I mean, that's how, you know,
like what you see in your social network,
it's what people are talking about, right?
And so I think that that's
another part of the story
that gets left out on independents, right?
I think what you were saying is right.
They're the clueless people, right?
I mean, if you're living in this country
and don't understand what's up, right?
Then you're gonna swing back and forth.
But if you're in that,
like, Madison or, like,
in Wisconsin and you're, you know,
you go to a diner for
breakfast every morning,
you're sitting at the
big table in the middle,
you know who you're
supposed to vote for, right?
And if you're in a different place
where it isn't, like, acute politics,
you don't, and so you're,
like, wagging back and forth.
And I think there are
lots of things like that
that we don't take into
the analysis and story
about why we get the results we do.
- If I can follow up on with Mike,
so there's all this talk
of the nationalization
of American politics
with the demise of local
media and people relying
more on national sources with people,
you know, tuning into
national social media
rather than a local sense,
people knowing less about their national,
their local candidates even,
as they know more about the differences
between the national
parties, as Lynn was sharing.
If it's true that there's this
nationalization of American politics,
why does it matter if
you're an independent voter
in California or an
independent voter in Georgia?
Or do you think we as political scientists
might be overstating the case
of this nationalization
of American politics?
- I think that what I should say is that
it's not...
It's sensitive to the context
in the moment, right?
That during the, you know,
Trump administration years, right?
You could not hide anywhere
and not hear about all this stuff, right?
And in the last two years,
if you're not living
in one of these states
where they're doing scam
audits or, you know,
doing lots of high visibility things,
you can, and if you're
not really clued in,
then you kind of think things
have gone back to normal.
And so I don't think you
can say there's, like,
one way to understand independent voters
in every state at all times, right?
- So in some sense, Biden being boring
has brought back this less
of a national dimension
that existed under Trump.
- Yeah, no, I think that
that's been a big problem
for the first year and a half,
was that he was really going
against the only motivation
that would get people to do
what they ended up doing.
- Good. Okay.
Any other follow ups on
that line of discussion?
One question I was wondering
about as this discussion
was going on was,
is there an implication
of the calcification ideas
or that candidate quality
would be less important?
And if so,
is that what you're
predicting that we'll see,
'cause it did seem like
some of the arguments
Josh and I think Mo
might have made as well,
was that, and I think
it's anecdotal evidence,
I haven't seen, I've seen
a little bit of analysis,
was that the, you know,
"candidate quality" problem
really did manifest itself.
And you know, you can
see it in the difference
between up and down ballot voting
and some of these cases
among other indicators.
- For sure.
Ohio and Pennsylvania are
great examples of that.
- Georgia.
- And yeah, I would say that,
you know, I'm never gonna say
that candidate quality
is irrelevant. (laughs)
- That's true. (chuckles)
- And I think that
what we're saying is that
take the argument that
Mo made a minute ago
about those swing voters
being critically important now
and, you know, what's swinging them.
I think of these swing voters as being,
they're trying to speak a language
and their dictionary's a little broken.
Like, they're trying to
participate in politics,
but, like, they just,
they don't pay attention,
they don't watch the news,
they don't understand the issues,
they don't really care about very much.
And so, and that is,
I know that that really
sounds, like, disparaging
and I didn't mean it to sound that way.
But they're trying to communicate.
Their dictionary's a little broken.
So things like candidate quality,
that really means a lot,
'cause it's easy to
understand, it's accessible.
And so I think that we wouldn't say
that it's, you know, it may
be affecting fewer people
than it has in the past,
but it may be pivotal as ever.
- Yeah, actually I'm gonna jump
on the candidate quality thing,
because I think this really
needs to be differentiated.
Candidate quality absolutely matters
for governor, right?
Because it doesn't have
this national implication.
That's how you get Hogan or Baker
or something like that
by people who are voting
70/30 Democratic nationally.
So, you know, if you,
I can't even remember the
guy in Maryland where I live,
who is, like, the wacko
MAGA Republican, right?
Who got about seven
votes this time, right?
I mean, that's candidate quality
at the gubernatorial level.
And so I think if we're
talking candidate quality,
we really should just limit it.
They are two different questions.
The other thing, though,
and this is where I think sometimes we,
because we are, like, grounded
in polls and attitudes,
rather than if you go to focus groups
or talk to voters and all that,
it's not that people just have
different attitudes about policies,
it's that we've evolved different ways
of living in the country.
And so it isn't just about, you know,
is this person agreeing with me,
but could I lose the right to an abortion?
Right?
Like, in my life, right?
It's a different thing.
And so I think Kari Lake
offers a really good
counter example, because
if you turn the volume off
and sorry, Katie,
she was, like, one of the best candidates
this time around.
She had deep roots and
credibility as a news anchor.
She came across well.
It's just that people
understood what she was gonna do
to the state, right?
That's not, when we think
of bad candidate quality,
we think of Sharron Angle or
Aiken or Mastriano, right?
So I think it's, we have to parse out,
that there's a substantive
dimension to this
in this MAGA era that is different
from their bad politicians.
- Yeah, no, that's fair.
Yeah, I think it was even the case,
I haven't looked at this in quite a while,
but back in the day I looked at candidates
for Senate elections and
if I remember correctly,
one of the fake outs, in a sense,
was the governor of the wrong party
who looked like they would be
a very good candidate for Senate.
And when they moved up,
tried to move up from Senate,
from governor, they sometimes did well.
Well, they were governor after all.
But they were not the, they often lost.
And they often weren't able to move
from being the governor of the,
so a governor of Massachusetts
would be an example,
as you were saying.
They were very good governors.
They weren't gonna be
able to go to federal,
equivalent level federal
office for the obvious reasons.
And I imagine that might even be
more of a problem this time around
in this era.
Okay, other questions or
comments by panelists?
- Can I just add one more?
- Please.
- You know, the House incumbency advantage
has declined steadily over,
like, the last 20 or 25 years.
And I think it's directly
tied to the party differences
we've talked about here,
that in an era when
basically it doesn't matter
which Republican you elect,
it's gonna vote the same
way as any other Republican,
and the committees are centralized
and under the leadership
of the leadership.
So it's simply a question of
do you want Mitch McConnell
or Chuck Schumer in the House?
I mean, do you want Nancy
Pelosi or Kevin McCarthy
to be the speaker?
And so I think that's why people
are simply not paying
nearly as much attention
to who their House incumbents are
as they were 20, 25 years ago.
- Other thoughts?
Just one other question just because I,
this is such an interesting
group of scholars
and observers of American politics.
And I think we'll probably end up going,
when we go to the question and answer,
right back to political
behavior and elections.
Does anyone care to offer comments
about implications
of their assessments for governance?
For what this means for...
Or for what is the public policy output,
the democratic, you know,
the implications for
democracy, things like that.
So what implications, what have you,
what is your take away
after this election regarding prospects?
Or have you learned
anything from this election
or do you have anything you wanna share
regarding your views about governance
or the state of our democracy?
- It looks bad.
- Yeah, would you care to elaborate?
(guests laugh)
Dr. Fiorina?
- Well, I mean,
what is Congress gonna do?
They're just revving up investigations,
and we're sort of starting on
the 2024 campaign right now.
And Republicans are gonna
obviously have a big fight
between the MAGA types
who want to get back
at every Democrat they can think about,
and they're gonna be
conducting investigations,
and a wing that would like
to show they might have some
ability to govern should
they get a majority
and should they win the presidency.
And, you know, I just think the Democrats
are gonna be frustrated,
not being able to get anything done.
So I think two years, nothing happens.
Things just get worse.
- I think it was a complete
disaster, catastrophe
for governance and for, like,
people will look back on this
as a really big loss moment.
If you remember, like, after
the second impeachment trial,
the sort of savvy opinion
and all the people
who were sort of talking
about what comes next,
that people wanted to move on.
That if you went after Trump or the people
who were trying to
overturn the government,
everyone would see it as partisan
and that, you know, just can't do that.
But when the J6 hearing started,
it turned out that's not
what people think, right?
People actually want a
government that enforces the law,
and that, in fact, over these last years
when, you know, the banks, everybody else
has been too big to jail, I think there's,
and we see this in focus groups
and, like, a lot of things,
people want accountability.
And I think the, you know,
if any of you had been asked
if the Democrats held a J6 hearing
the second week of October
and they raided Mar-a-Lago,
whether everyone, voters would just think,
"Oh, that's just partisan politics,"
you'd say, "Of course."
But that isn't what happened.
And so what's gonna happen now
because Republicans are
gonna do what Mo just said,
is we are going to muddy this, right?
They are going to take what
was coming to be a consensus
about the unacceptability of what happened
and create this confusion,
continue the idea that there
was something illegitimate.
And so, like, yeah, there's
a lot of stuff about,
you know, passing bills
and all the other things.
But we really almost had
a moment where we could
get back on track on rule of law
and a sort of coming together
around accountability.
And that's kind of shot.
- I'll give the contrarian.
I don't know if I believe
what I'm about to say,
but I'll give a contrarian
optimistic take, which is...
What we've been seeing over
the last couple of years
is, as Lynn showed really good data on,
is that people see differences
between the two parties.
They recognize that when
you're voting for Democrats,
you are getting Nancy
Pelosi or Chuck Schumer,
and that means a certain
consolation of ideas.
Or when you're voting for Republicans,
you are voting for Kevin
McCarthy and Mitch McConnell,
you're getting a certain
constellation of ideas
and certain constellation of policies.
And it means now that
voters are being guided more
by these differences,
these policy differences
between the parties and that, you know,
maybe the optimistic take is that
voters are gonna get what they want.
They're going to get this
policy that's reflective
of who they're voting for,
because they now recognize the stakes
of the policy stakes of
who they're voting for.
They're no longer voting for
their local member of Congress
because they're a good
guy or whatever it may be.
They're now voting for
their member of Congress
because they want Nancy Pelosi
or because they want Kevin McCarthy.
They're guided by these
policy motivations.
Whether or not they end up getting that
is limited by the bicameralism
and all the veto points
in American politics.
But I think the optimistic
take on voter behavior
on individual voters
is that they're seeing
these policy differences,
these major differences
between the parties.
And I think that could be encouraging.
- I'll pick up on the optimism thread,
'cause everybody always tells me
that the calcification
argument is a real bummer.
And just say that, Alan, like,
you asked about policy and...
The policies that affect people's lives
can come from places other than Congress.
So gridlock and Congress, for sure.
Don't disagree with any of that.
But the word that I would use to describe
what kinds of policy environment people
are gonna be living in is just whiplash.
So you elect Donald Trump
and maybe he writes a
bunch of executive orders,
changes the world in one direction.
You elect Joe Biden, he comes in,
undoes all of that back
in the other direction.
And so a lot, and they're so far apart,
that for voters, I think a lot of what
it's gonna feel like is whiplash.
It was this, it was that.
Policy is devolving down to states.
There's one policy in California,
there's another policy in Ohio.
So it's going to be very, you know,
very different over time and space.
And then on the democracy front,
I would say that before
the midterm elections,
I was worried that we would
see continued backsliding.
People who lost elections
would not concede,
they would call on their supporters
to march on their state
capitol or some such.
And the fact that we
saw very little of that,
I think was a really important
moment for democracy.
So also an optimistic note.
- Great.
I think this is a very interesting topic,
and I just want to give the panelists
who spoke early in the round
to have the opportunity
to respond if they,
and to add any other comments
they want to before we move
to the audience questions.
Seeing limited desire to do so,
why don't we move on to the questions,
and let me just remind our audience,
just send along questions,
and I'm gonna try and read the questions
that you send along.
So send them along in a
form that is friendly,
friendly for that purpose.
Okay, so let me just get started
with some of those questions.
So here's a question.
I'd like to give Mike a chance
to spin out his argument further.
If the crucial question is
how a GOP that tripled down
on Trumpism after January 6th
still captured the House,
how does a focus on turnout
and a distinction between
the MAGA battlefield
and other races answer that question?
- Yeah, so, thanks.
I think the framework
that I'm coming at it from is that
in November, 2020, as much
probably as any election ever,
people understood that it was
about four more years of MAGA or not.
And when that happened,
81 million people voted
for not four more years of MAGA.
Which means that in almost
every race that mattered,
there were more people
who had voted against MAGA
than there were who had
voted for it, right?
And so, to me,
the MAGA will continue
to be defeated
to the extent that that group of voters
understands that that's what
this election is about again.
And if they don't, then
they're not habitual voters.
They just sort of go back to not voting.
And that's the problem.
And this is where the asymmetry
in information environments
is really undermining democracy
and sort of our hopes, right?
For the people who are
living in Fox world,
they know every election is existential,
that Democrats are
pedophiles and the devil,
and why they have to
sort of go out and vote.
And the mainstream media and
the people who are trusted
wobble on it, right?
And when, you know, over
June through mid-September
when the mainstream media
was very much covering J6,
Mar-a-Lago, Dobbs, all of that,
you saw this big movement
towards Democrats
and the generic and all of those things.
These people are being
reminded what's at stake.
And then you get the reversal
where the media says, "Oh, no.
People don't care about it anymore.
We're gonna cover other stuff."
And suddenly the air starts
coming out of the balloon.
Right?
But my point is that-
- I was just gonna say, Mike.
So I just wanna call your attention
to one part of the question.
The question of the differential patterns
in the MAGA versus the non MAGA states,
how that fit in.
- Oh, yeah.
Just that, what I was saying is that
in the MAGA and non-MAGA-
- I'm sorry, the MAGA battlefield states.
- The MAGA war zone.
MAGA war zone and the rest of the states,
Republican House candidates in both places
got about 3/4 of the
number of votes Trump got.
And in the MAGA war zone,
Democrats got about 73%,
74, almost parity.
And in the other areas, only 66%.
And when we get the voter
file, we can parse that more,
but the point is that there just weren't
Democrats coming out in the same intensity
in the rest of the country.
And that's right,
if they're not on full alert.
And although, you know, one of the things,
if you go back and look
at 2018 or 2014, whatever,
you do not see these big regional,
there's no regional difference
between the competitive states
and the non-competitive states
in the previous presidential race
and turn out in the midterm, right?
It's just not sensitive to it.
It's a new, different phenomenon.
- Okay, great.
Thank you very much.
Okay, next question.
Could the panelists address whether
there are really demographic
shifts within the country
that are going to impact
either party in the future?
Okay, yeah.
There's another part to the question.
But let's start out with
demographics and voting patterns.
I mean, I think that, you know,
I think this is in the spirit of Teixeira
arguments about, so
maybe, maybe Mo Fiorina,
if you care to start.
- Sure. I'd be happy to.
One of the main pieces of the argument
of the emerging Democratic majority
is the growing number of the
immigrants, especially Latinos.
And obviously it hasn't
worked out that way,
but I wrote a piece in
"RealClearPolitics" on this.
There's a really important
book by a demographer
by the name Richard Alba
at Princeton, or no,
he's published by Princeton Press.
And you've probably all read
this about how we will have
a non-white majority by 2045 or so.
And the demographers point
out that that is really,
that prediction is based
on a very strange way
of counting whites and non-whites.
And I have slides on
this, which I, (laughs)
it probably would take me too
long to try to pull them up.
But just to give an example,
Senator Cruz is half Cuban,
so the census counts him as non-white.
He has two daughters, his
wife, forget her name,
but she's a northern European.
He has two daughters who are 1/4 Cuban.
They're counted in the
census as non-white.
If the daughters have kids in 2045,
and say they married totally, again,
Norwegians or something like that,
the kids who are 1/8 Cuban
will be counted as non-white.
That if you, it's basically
a Jim Crow in reverse
that if you're counting,
if you have anything other
than non-Hispanic white in you,
you are counted as a person of color.
And out of any kind of reasonable
way of counting people,
it turns out that those
projections are way off,
and they go on to show that
there's a tremendous amount
of intermarriage going on.
That, in other words, the
kind of examples I've given
are what's actually occurring in reality.
And the, you know,
it's sort of politically
incorrect in some circles
to talk about the great
American melting pot,
but it's boiling away
as much as it ever did,
especially with Hispanics.
And so, the bottom line is neither party
should basically base its stage
on expectations of demography
delivering for you,
because it's not gonna happen.
What's gonna determine elections
is issues and performance
as it has in the past.
- So I am really happy for this question.
Because this is something that, like,
bothers me no end as someone who actually
tries to win elections,
is that if you are running a campaign,
either, like, whatever you're doing,
you're not sitting there thinking,
"Well, like, how do I do
with this demographic group?"
You're thinking, "How do I get
everybody who agrees with me
to vote for me?"
Right?
And you're thinking about
there's no intermediate step
of whether they're Latino
or a suburban voter
or something like that, right?
You are building a coalition of people
who agree with different
parts of what you want to do.
And it's incidental, right?
It's descriptive statistics afterwards
to say that it was because they were this
or that demographic group, right?
And there are only two
demographic groups, to me,
that are large and matter
where it actually operates in that way.
And that's white evangelicals
and African-Americans.
Where there's such a close,
you know, to a 100% identity
with what that demographic
name is, you know?
But other than that, it's
just going back and counting
the number of people in
each of these categories
that ended up agreeing with you.
And that's why, like,
after every election,
people are, like, chasing these, like,
you know, you know,
narrating a turtle race
or something, right?
Because that's not what's determining
what they're gonna vote for.
They're doing it on the basis of, like,
how you put that coalition together.
- Further thoughts on this question?
Oh, or comments?
Okay. Seeing none.
- Actually, can I say
one other thing about it?
- Yes, of course.
- That is also, obviously
this is something
that exercises me, is that,
like many other things
in political analysis,
especially in the press
and everything like that,
there's just rampant
ecological fallacies, right?
Where everybody says,
"Oh, pick the group."
They just move this way
and everybody imagines
a particular person in that group
changing their mind rather than saying,
"Well, the group of people in that group
who voted this time is different."
Both things are going on, right?
And so it's, like, when
you have polls that say,
so, you know, suddenly
now people care less
about issue X or they
care more about issue X.
You don't even know whether or
not the people who've changed
their voting partisanship
or, like, their vote choice
are among the group that changed their...
Right?
It's just, we're really
sloppy about that stuff.
- Okay. Further thoughts?
All right, next question.
Which issues motivated
previously non-voters
to go to the polls?
And let me add to that
question a little bit.
Thinking back, say to 2018,
say, where we saw a really unusual,
unusual event, maybe you would
say it at different times,
but it was clearly
something unusual in 2018
and it, so what do you think is going on
with respect to some of the breaks
in the traditional turnout patterns
that we observed over the
last half decade or so?
- I'll just jump in quickly.
I have not done a
systematic analysis of this,
but my guess is that,
like, if I had to bet,
I would bet my money on
that it isn't so much
an issue as it is a sense among people
that their vote is
gonna make a difference.
So the election is gonna be close,
and a lot is at stake, right?
And so if you want me to describe issues
that I think make people feel that way,
they would be these identity-based issues.
So in 2018, Alan, you mentioned,
that's the aftermath
after the 2016 election,
which was decided in the electoral college
by 77,000 votes in three states.
And a very surprising
outcome that nobody expected.
And so in 2018 then
lots of people are like,
"Oh man, you know, I better participate."
And they're reacting to the change
in the conversation to
these identity-based issues.
And then again, in 2022,
in 2020 it's, you know, these,
everyone knows the elections
are gonna be close,
it was closer than 2016.
44,000 votes across three states
determine the 2020 presidential election.
And so that gets us a
boost in turnout in 2022.
So I think it's not just one
issue makes people go vote.
It's this sense of there's a lot at stake
and, "Man, these
elections are really close
and my vote might really matter."
- Yeah.
And also on this one,
I have a very empirical answer,
because we have it on the voter file.
The first thing is that this election
will have very few non-voters coming out.
There are very few folks who decided
that '20 wasn't important
enough, but this one was.
But in '18, the big
boost was really among,
one of the big hidden
ones that you can't see
without a voter file is
pre-presidential Democratic voters
who decided, "This is a
midterm I need to vote in."
So it wasn't so much
people coming outta nowhere
and deciding to vote.
It was people who had
actually been pretty regular
presidential year voters
deciding in all of the
hothouse anti-Trump stuff
that they better come out
and vote in 2018 as well.
- Just one other observation that
although the individual issues might
affect a lot of the, you
know, election swings
in terms of just this being
a much more high turnout era,
that also goes back to the parties
rediscovering get out the vote
and suddenly being in the early 2000s
with the Republican's 24/7 project
and in proceeding, there's
just been a lot more
mobilization effort in
the last two decades
than there was even a
couple decades earlier.
- There you go.
Okay.
Any more observations on
that before we move on?
Okay.
Here's a question.
A year ago, David Brooks observed
that the issue dividing the parties
was shifting from pro versus con,
the role of government
that has dominated politics
since the New Deal to America
first versus globalism.
Do you see any evidence
that this is occurring?
So...
Lynn, you're on mute.
- Sorry, it's my first Zoom.
Yeah, sounds a lot like
calcification to me.
Not exactly the same idea,
but this idea that there's a shifting away
from this New Deal dimension
onto something else.
- You mentioned the idea
that, I'm sorry, Josh,
why don't you go and then
I had a follow up for Lynn.
- Yeah, I don't know if,
like, Brooks' characterization
of globalism is right for
the current dimension.
I mean, we see on free trade
that Joe Biden, for example,
is very much continuing Donald trade,
Donald Trump's anti-free trade policies.
And on the Inflation Reduction Act,
Joe Biden is very much
focused on build in America,
subsidize American production
and American first kind
of manufacturing policy.
So while there might be some of this shift
away from New Deal,
I don't know if the dimension
is American first versus globalism.
Also, I do wonder, Lynn, what we'll see
in the next two years with Republicans
as they control the House,
whether or not they bring back
a focus on New Deal issues,
on tax cuts and Obamacare.
Like, what is a Kevin McCarthy
House going to look like
when it comes to spending bills?
- Yeah.
- Further thoughts?
Okay, let's see.
Okay, according to election exit polls,
Trump was more of a factor
than former presidents usually are.
Carries a strong negative, net negative.
Was he and his (indistinct)
of election deniers
the determining element
in the close election
and therefore the partisan
divide in both houses?
I think you sort of, yeah,
we heard a little about that, I think,
in the various presentations.
Please, Lynn?
- Well, I was just gonna say, like,
don't just, I mean, not
every election is close.
But in the ones that are close enough
for something like the legacy
of Trump to make a difference,
anything is making a difference, right?
So, like, don't try to not
think of it's one thing.
Like, it's all of these things.
You know, not in every race,
but in the ones where you think one thing
could have made the difference,
it's not just one thing.
It's gonna be a lot of these things.
- Okay. Further thoughts on that?
- Yeah, no, go ahead.
- Please, Mike.
- We've been on this for a while
and I'm taking too much time.
Go ahead.
- Okay, so here's another question.
What influence will voter
suppression measures
have on the 2024 election?
Do you think that will
be an important factor?
- So I think that,
I mean, it depends on
what you're gonna define
as voter suppression and sort of the,
I think that one of the
problems with the way
we study the anti-voting,
anti-democracy laws
is we look at them, like,
will this one provision change this thing
rather than what the accumulation
of Shelby, Citizens
United, Brnovich, Rucho,
and everything else has done to change
in an unrecognizable way
the way elections happen
in the United States, right?
And the one to the point, right,
go back to the idea of, like,
there's insurrection
and no one even thinks,
"Well, will they be held
accountable at the polling places?"
Considered that
of the 90 Republicans who ran,
who voted against the electoral college
and were running in states where
Republicans drew the districts,
only one was not in a safe seat, right?
Voters never got a chance
to hold accountable them for this.
And there's a way in which the
sort of public discussion is,
"Well, it must be fair
because neither party has an advantage."
But democracy and voters
don't have an advantage
if we don't get to actually
exercise a choice in elections,
especially after such a
momentous event, right?
And that doesn't get measured
in, like, a difference,
a different study on this
voter provision, right?
But the in the aggregate, you-
- I was gonna say, we actually
just saw such a paper.
Josh and I just saw such a
paper this very day. (laughs)
- But the point is, that,
like, there's stuff that,
like, you can just see
from outer space, right?
And in terms of how American
elections have changed.
And it's the foundation for why we have,
you know, a MAGA House of Representatives.
- Let me ask one last question,
because we're getting close
to the end of our time.
This is a question.
This program is great,
and I would love to get beyond
what I read in the press.
Would the panelists give
us a few academic papers
to pull and read and let me just say,
also maybe a recommendation or website
or places to go for commentary
and news that they would recommend
as especially insightful
and maybe a different voice
than you would hear
and that would allow you to get beyond
what I read in the press.
I guess it is, of course the press.
But you know what I mean.
Okay, any ideas, friends?
- "The Bitter End" by Sides,
Tausanovitch and Vavreck,
recently came out by
Princeton University Press
and it's a fantastic book,
as well as Mo's work.
- Thank you, Josh.
- Mo, is "Unstable Majorities"
your most recent book?
Am I getting that one right?
- Yes.
- So "The Bitter End"
and "Unstable Majorities"
by two of our panelists are
fantastic books to read.
(Lynn chuckles)
- Well, thank you, Josh.
- Thank you.
If you want commentary
on day-to-day politics,
I mentioned Ruy Teixeira
as the Liberal Patriot.
There are several readers
or several writers,
but he is particularly
good on just an analysis
sort of in between the
academic political science
and journalism.
And, you know, I just think,
well, look at it every
time he writes something.
- Other recommendations, please.
- I was just gonna say,
I asked my graduate students
in our last meeting,
this quarter, what the best
thing was that they read
all quarter long, and then they
made me participate as well.
And so I'm gonna share with you the paper
that I read this quarter.
So that doesn't mean it just came out,
but it's when I read it.
It's a paper actually by some Yale folks.
I don't know how to say
this woman's first name.
I think it, is it Lila or Lilla Orr?
O-R-R, and our friend and
your colleague Greg Huber.
And this is a paper that is in,
I think it's in the "American
Political Science Review,"
and it is about sorting out
how much of people's reactions
to the parties are purely based on emotion
and how much of it has a
policy component to it.
And it's not a mystery novel,
so I'll just give away the finding,
is that a good deal of people's reactions,
emotional reactions to the party
or to people's party labels,
comes from the beliefs
about what they wanna do
in the world.
So we hear, you know, "Oh,
like, I don't want my son
or daughter to marry a Republican
or marry a Democrat."
"Ah!" And it's emotion.
But what they sort out is
that actually a lot of that
is because you wouldn't want your child
to marry someone who holds those beliefs.
And it isn't just emotional.
It's a really, really
creative and nice paper.
- I'll give another answer as well,
which is read political science journals.
So I mean, some of our journals
are the "American
Political Science Review,"
the "American Journal
of Political Science."
Look at the abstracts, look
at the table of contents.
Don't pay for the articles,
but if you see an article
that really interests you,
email the author and those
authors are always happy
to send those PDFs to folks.
So if you see a paper that interests you,
feel free to reach out.
Don't send long rambling
emails to academics,
but if you want, like, a little PDF,
we're more than happy to share those PDFs.
- Right, so I think we're gonna see a run
on the "American
Political Science Review."
- I was just gonna say.
I already sent a field
experiment from Alan
about emailing random political scientists
to see if they'll send
PDFs to people. (chuckles)
- Did I? Okay. (laughs)
- Who's more likely to respond?
- Well, I'm sure that's,
some version of that has been done
and many times, I assume.
By all sorts of people,
including graduate students
and undergraduates.
So all very good.
Mike, do you have anything
you wanna recommend?
- I don't think so. No.
I love not just "The Bitter End,"
but the books before it.
- Oh, thank you.
- I think they're the
best by volume recaps
of all of the things.
And I think one of the things that I think
is really great about them,
is that you,
is the way you take different topics
that are, were of interest
during the election
and find a way to explore them
in a smart, data-based way.
- Thanks.
- Which usually is never the case
when they're discussed in public.
And so I thought those were really good.
- Great.
- Thank you.
- Terrific.
- I did think of-
- Please.
- I thought of a podcast,
I thought, just my
favorite political podcast
is "Hacks on Tap," which is
David Axelrod and Mike Murphy.
And they are not doing policy,
but they are talking about
elections and strategy
and the kinds of things
that campaign consultants talk about.
And so if you like that kind of thing,
which it sounds like from the Q&A.
people sort of do, I recommend it.
It's funny and it's all,
it's weekly and super relevant.
- Yeah, actually I'll do one other thing,
but which is just category,
more of a category
that I think is really underappreciated,
is what I've seen in new attempts
to have
analysis of political economy
where it's not just about one more person
doing or on surveys,
but really understanding
things like path dependency
in our country and the different
ways, economic interests,
all those kinds of things.
And as kind of an old guy, right?
Like, that used to be the
way people understood things.
And I think if it's making a
comeback, that's a great thing.
- Great. Well, thank you.
Thank you all.
We're coming, I guess,
to the end of our time.
I wanna thank everyone for
attending tonight's session
and for the excellent questions.
I'm very grateful to all the panelists
for their thoughtful contributions
to our conversation today.
Again, Mo Fiorina, Josh
Kalla, Mike Podhorzer,
and Lynn Vavreck.
Thank you again for contributing
your time to this event.
I also wanna, once again,
thank my colleagues
at ISPS, Pam Greene, Rick Harrison,
Limor Peer, and Kira Wishart,
who worked to help get this event
put together today.
I'm very grateful to all they do
to further the ISPS mission
of research and teaching.
And then I finally wanna mention that
we're going to do this again in a week.
We're gonna have the
second elections panel,
because there's so much more
to think about and reflect on.
And so you'll, for those
of you on our mailing list,
you'll be receiving additional
information about that soon.
And I also wanna welcome you
to visit the ISPS website
where we post information
about all of our events.
Again, thank you all very much,
and I wish you happy holidays
and a wonderful evening.
Good night.
- Thank you.